dos encuentros dos estilos radicalmente
diferentes
donald trump por un lado camina
libremente ignorando las recomendaciones
de salud como a lo largo de su campaña
por otro lado yo vaivén mucho más
reservado con un comité reducido y
respetando el distanciamiento social si
el candidato demócrata viera las
encuestas a nivel nacional el presidente
de eeuu tiene una pequeña ventaja en el
estado clave de florida hogar de cuatro
millones de latinoamericanos
según las encuestas que estoy seguro de
que son las encuestas reales ahora
estamos ganando a los demócratas por
primera vez con los hispanoamericanos la
primera vez siempre los he amado y creo
que ellos siempre me han amado
dos enfoques pero una sola estrategia en
el estado del sol se trata de una
operación para seducir a la comunidad
latina el voto de la primera minoría en
eeuu podría ser decisivo menos del 50
por ciento de los hispanos votan en
general pero este año podrían ser mucho
más numerosos en particular debido al
rápido deterioro de su situación
económica
a trump le gusta hablar pero a él no le
importan los cubanos ni los venezolanos
ni siquiera otorgará estatus de
protección temporal a los venezolanos
que huyen del régimen opresivo de maduro
los jubilados son otro grupo que le
interesa a ambos candidatos representan
más del 20 por ciento de la población un
electorado que tiende a votar por los
republicanos pero que podría irse contra
trump acusado de haber tomado malas
decisiones durante la pandemia